my name is brent the cesar and i'm half
of wd detailing and today we're going to
be cleaning a super moldy car that has
grass growing in it mold water and all
of the above it was absolutely
disgusting
[Music]
first we put the ozone machine inside
the car that basically pumps oxygen to
the third degree into it or ozone and it
suffocates the bacteria and kills it
and then we'll pull the seats out after
we do the ozone treatment so we can
actually get to all the spots that we
need to
and then the first thing that we'll do
is vacuum it try to get all the debris
or in this case the mold and the water
out of it so we can really get in the
car and work on it
so here we're working with where all of
the water ended up going the water was
only on half of the car
and i think that's because of where the
leak was located so what you're looking
at right now is us vacuuming up all of
that water
the last time that this car was plated
was in 2015 so ended up sitting for the
last six years and just about five
months ago the owner noticed that there
was an issue with the sunroof where it
wouldn't close all the way and water was
continuously getting in there but we've
never seen anything like this before
for a car like this it's actually
recommended to remove the carpet throw
it away and replace it
but for some reason in this specific car
it was stapled down completely to the
point where if we were gonna remove it
it wasn't gonna go back in and sit the
way that it would need to for this car
it was definitely a different process
than when we would normally extract a
car because the carpet was basically
stained with that green mold and we had
to try to figure out a way to push it
out of the fibers of the carpet and see
if the carpet would revive to the white
color that it ended up being so the
first thing that we did which we
normally would not do is use the tornado
attachment which is compressed air that
shoots out in a circle like a tornado
almost you have like a little
compartment where you put all-purpose
cleaner in mixed with water so you
dilute it and you attach it to an air
hose on an air compressor and it really
gets into the fibers of that cloth and
kind of blows out anything that might be
in there
so we blew out the entire carpet with it
after vacuuming it
and then we'll go ahead and we'll use
our extractor soap on it and spray like
a healthy amount on there and we'll
actually use the extractor which shoots
hot water into the carpet to get the
carpet a little bit more wet because
when we use our drill brush we want to
try to reduce the amount of friction
that we're putting into the carpet
because if there's too much friction if
it's not wet enough
then it can actually damage the carpet
we'll use our drill brush to agitate all
of that soap so we'll go over it a few
times get it really into the fibers and
then we'll use our hot water extractor
which only has water in it we don't ever
recommend putting any kind of soaps or
anything in your extractor because when
you're blowing the water into the carpet
you want to suck everything out and if
you have soap in it it's just going to
add more to it and it's not going to be
completely clean
i actually filled half of of shop back
full of water
so i think i actually got probably 95
to 99 of the water out
when you do the doors it's the same
thing as doing any of the other plastics
in the car in this case we use tri-clean
which is made to kill bacteria and all
that stuff inside of cars while most
all-purpose cleaners do kill bacteria we
wanted something that is a little bit
stronger especially because in this case
there's a lot more mold than you would
normally see in a regular car
and then use the tornado attachment or
some soft bristle brushes and really get
in every nook and cranny and make sure
we clean it up
[Music]
so for this part he's actually drying
off the door and getting all the liquid
out of the nooks and crannies so that is
the tornado attachment but that's a
different one than the one that is used
for specifically cleaning so this
tornado attachment doesn't have the
canister that holds any kind of cleaner
and this one just blows out air so you
use that to get into cracks and crevices
where you normally couldn't with a brush
or with a microfiber towel
or you use it to get under seats
when we do leather seats that have been
sitting in mold the first thing we do
with any seat is vacuum it just to get
any kind of debris especially in the
crevice where the bottom and the back of
the seat meet
we'll use an all-purpose cleaner or a
leather cleaner they're two different
things a leather cleaner is more
suitable for high-end leather and then
he'll spray it on there use a color lock
brush so it's like a really fine
strong brush to get into all of the
pores of the seat
when we're cleaning leather seats we
don't use too much pressure just because
you don't want to damage them you could
leave scratches you could tear them
spray it again use the steamer to kill
any bacteria and then wipe that away too
when we do the wheels the first thing we
like to do is pressure wash them off and
get any of that initial dirt or grime
off of them
we have some heavy acid that we'll use
if it's really bad but we don't use it
on painted rims
and then we'll go ahead and we'll
agitate it with a brush and we'll use a
few different brushes to really get in
both the wheel well
on the tire inside the rim in the drum
of the rim
and then we'll go ahead and pressure
wash it away
so for the exterior because it had been
sitting out for so long over time if you
don't clean it grime will get attached
to the paint and start growing mold
because we did the exterior of the car
first we weren't too worried about water
getting in since it was already full of
water so we just went ahead and we
pressure washed everything out we put
paint safe degreaser all over the paint
because it just had a really thick layer
of both mold and grime on it that
wouldn't just come off with an initial
pressure wash we let it sit for about
two to three minutes and then we
pressure washed it again and then we'll
go ahead and we'll use the foam cannon
so the foam is just a car soap and you
just put it into a foam cannon and you
attach it to your pressure washer it
acts as a lubricant for any dirt that's
on the car so when you go to wash it
you're really minimizing how much
scratching can happen to the paint
and then we'll go ahead and we'll use
our microfiber mitts to wash it and then
spray it off
the absolute best way to store a car if
it's going to be outside is with some
sort of car cover or a tarp that way no
water is going to get on the top of the
car and find its way into the car it'll
keep the paint clean and away from all
the elements if it's going to be a car
that you're not driving for extended
periods of time you still want to look
in it and make sure nothing's going
wrong because seals can give and if they
do and water starts getting in then
that's a whole world of problems so the
best way to stop mold is to be proactive
and
check on your car before it actually
starts growing
when it comes to detailing i believe
it's best to maybe get a full detail
once to twice a year maybe three times i
always tell people to vacuum it if not
every few weeks at least once a month